[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no it's not unreasonable at all
excuse me take it the boss lady's on a
warpath this morning I really think I
could help this company you just gave me
a chance just concentrate on being my
assistant where you always mean I got
big and I got rich so now we're gonna
check me boo I wish for my age and I
check you I wish you were little I told
you watch it you want to bet groaning
look up white people cause black people
don't have the time Child Protective
Services enrolled this child in school
or somebody is going to jail everyone
else you're a child so you acting like a
body looks like baby damn Gymboree ass
gospel guys to me bye damn girl lookin
like cookie from Empire I could tell
that you are a special young lady effect
again no I feel like I get you to say
feel what I'm feeling no I'm not feeling
that at all don't don't look at me like
that
just look look look at the other way
look through it look the look up there
what is going on you're too fast for
that skirt okay I've been looking at you
like a little girl but she would grow an
apple me we have a BMW situation black
mama whooping your kids mom you're my
mama any parent or guardian of a child
during the ages of mandatory attendance
shall send such shout to public school
private school or a home schooling
program so what now
say what now is enroll this child in
school or somebody is going to jail
that's what now say what that's somebody
do you mean you that would be you now
enroll her there today and I will be
checking that you do so no mm-hmm look
here lady I am a businesswoman and I
have a company to run
that's girl scout cookies this she
thinks it really seriously I might so I
don't have time for child services and I
sure don't have time for school okay let
me be clear I will have you in foster
care and a goofy aunt over here in jail
if you don't
okuu jordan feathers calling hello
are you awake yeah I was meditating
betta wait what I call but I don't know
when you're gonna call so when would I
sleep when I'm not calling April listen
to me I'm sick this morning
oh why I have asked you a thousand times
to have my housekeeper Elaine Linda is
her name Linda my slippers sixty-three
centimeters away from the bed so when I
hop out my feet you land on them I mean
am I being unreasonable is that too much
to ask
no it's not unreasonable at all I will
agree to cover for you at the office if
you agree to promote me to creative exec
well look who's boss just dropped I
gotta take what I want
isn't that what you said maybe so do you
deal yes does that have to be you I
should probably just apart and then
borrow some of your clothes your body
can't fan to my clothes
this is squats this is Pilates that body
looks like baby cab Jim Murray asked
gospel gosh to me this doesn't make any
sense you want to read groan and then
you woke up no but that's for white
people cuz but you don't have the time I
know I can't even think of what could
possibly I don't know
I mean how did you go from if I have
never seen a better glow of April can
you help me and figure this out no
you're right sorry I was just focus
thank you
I got it what
Gucci Wayne you've had a better glove
than you I mean he's happy he's healthy
got a six-pack he has a really nice
smile I don't know if those are veneers
but people say we smile alike I think I
have a pretty interesting idea what you
do April
I don't really sound like that what I
didn't say anything
somebody said something yah yah need to
be quiet we're having a meeting up here
about important stuff she didn't say
anything he thought he heard something
y'all ain't said nothing Conner is out
the door unless we crack this and in
case that wasn't clear if Connor is out
the door all of you out bye-bye health
care which you know you need bye-bye
ping-pong table bye-bye ergonomic chair
which treats
you better stop quivering that lip you
better not cry this isn't about you
Melissa I'm sick of you then one more
thing I dare you fine
you're too fat for that skirt you know
what you want to take it there we're
going old school Oh
let's go requesting back-up we have a
BMW situation black mama whooping I've
been looking at you like a little girl
but she would grown-ass woman and you go
catch your chrome be fine cuz I got this
good me back whoa how about this April
should I sell them give that back to me
now me yes start spanking your kids
[Music]